Gitta hope has never been one to give up
for years she fought for this hiking
path and in the end helped make it a
reality the path lies along the border
between Austria and Slovenia but three
years ago a fence was built here to
prevent migrants from crossing it used
to be open always there was never a
fence or guard towers or things like
that
not when Yugoslavia was on the other
side and not after it became Slovenia
now no one on either side can cross
freely and undergrowth is taking over
the path
Austria's government ordered the fence
to send a message six months after tens
of thousands of refugees streamed over
the border in the autumn of 2015 the
government also promised to take it back
down again when the situation allowed
but now armed patrols are a regular
sight along the fence
another deterrence measure implemented
by Austria's new ruling coalition of
conservative and populist parties it's
even put on a major exercise simulating
a crisis at the border
those were dramatic images I'd almost
call them traumatic images we're talking
about countless thousands marching
towards our borders in columns and the
point is that back then those countless
thousands of foreigners didn't stop at
our borders the right-wing politician is
coping with what he calls the nation's
trauma by saying never again Interior
Minister how about kicker has set up a
border police unit called Puma and has
also got the military involved there are
helicopters in the air and riot control
vehicles on the streets little wonder
then that the simulation was called pro
borders Austria's right-wing extremists
have applauded the training exercise
while the government in Vienna makes no
secret of the fact that it's against a
Europe Without Borders
it's also no surprise that the people
who played the role of migrants in the
simulation acted like hooligans at a
soccer match but three years ago the
exhausted people who arrived at the
Austrian border had come hundreds of
kilometers on foot through the Balkans
you mertcan was one of them along with
his pregnant wife and young son now he
helps get her in her vineyard while she
gives him German lessons you mouth Khan
is an Afghan but was born in Iran his
parents had fled there trying to escape
the Taliban and the endless cycles of
war but Afghans in Iran have no
documents and no rights they don't have
a right to education when police beat
him for no reason breaking his nose he
decided to risk the long trip to Europe
with his family Yama Khan has helped out
at a number of vineyards in the area one
of the vintners would be glad to hire
him but he'd have to be granted asylum
first his first application was refused
he'd like to stay in Austria and is
doing all he can to integrate during our
interview he insisted on speaking German
you can I don't sleep well at night I'm
afraid I always have to think why why
did they refuse my application I have to
try again but that one might also be
refused
so I does and that would be it what can
I do that's fast that's connect the
quits are giving happiness the new
government has cut funding for German
classes under its program integration
should only begin to happen when someone
has refugee status or subsidiary
protection but that takes two and a half
to three years they're fueling fear you
really feel it want a CCH pupa both
Slovenia and Austria signed the Schengen
Agreement which largely abolished border
controls within the
and the border between the countries is
secure for another reason for the past
couple of years almost no migrants have
tried to cross here yet things are very
quiet in the area at the moment it
almost never happens in the last few
months we've had very few incidents to
be exact there was just one incident in
the last three months
despite that the patrols continue along
this border fence due to hope is angry
this utterly useless thing is still here
in the area and it's preventing
slovenians and Austrians from growing
together more in the region it's an
impossible situation
it's ruthless leaders as a receipts loss
but as Europe increasingly adopts a
fortress mentality for many fences like
these are starting to seem normal